i want to get all you guys involved
reach into your bags your pockets get
something out that you would like me to
rap about even if you're over there even
if you're down on these weird little
bean bags at the back okay get some out
i'm going to walk amongst you rap about
those things while you're doing that i'm
gonna get this magical helmet
which people tell me will keep me safe
from coronavirus when i'm getting close
to all your unvaccinated faces let's
drop that beat i'm gonna walk amongst
you we're gonna rap about this stuff
when we're done okay let's jump down
here make sure this is on full blast
mode this is the first thing we started
with we're starting very simple guys but
don't worry nice front row get involved
your intent clicking on here philantis
on the pen that's the name of the
company you work for i like it clicking
on the bottom i adore color of the ink
maybe blue pick another the red ball
sugar free i discover i gave it to my
brother i shake it up i'm like a teen
getting energetic with the caffeine it's
ever so crazy i keep myself up at night
bringing a mouse to the convention why
is so confusing you wanna get respect
collette clicking all around with the
logitech that's the truth bluetooth and
i'll say a weird little thing like the
top of a cray on maybe i can look inside
so you drop like a tiny little nipple
and it's from the body shop strange put
it there on your teeth on your boob
looking kind of offensive but though do
don't even matter anything for this
little rapper if you've got the breath
that'd be better i'll have to put it
last around my ears protect me from the
virus of face mask 3 ply yes i provide
this and this guy yeah we got more dough
100 more euros for the airpods pro
careful that they don't break and don't
lose one some money by guys yeah i'm
just move on euros in a baggie what's
that thug it doesn't make sense maybe
exchange it for the drugs when it's
there in the little ziploc earring from
your ear kind of clean when i hit pop i
could walk around pendling dangling from
my lobe you should disinfect that now
that i've chose i've really touched that
and what is this let me see it's a hair
tie with the symbol infinity going round
never even hate turn it that way
vertical number eight and now to my dude
oh it's not hard it's my delo he just
provides his card it doesn't have your
name it just says global logistics is
this company good yeah i will slip it in
my pocket and now this for this fella if
it starts raining pop up this umbrella
it says pizarra that's never a brand
that i've heard before but you all will
understand it's unlucky what you guys
giving me a thing oh very nice it's a
little ring it likes to monitor yourself
with the lasers inside i've got my own
bling yeah the rings i provide and this
is your lanyard hello from the
university that's laura tillo it says
visitor oh like the polo shirt like the
blue color yeah i won't flirt anymore
here's a little card so many on the
clean strawberry on the back so messy
why have you got the dirt on the side it
goes well you and i going back to your
hotel i'm also on over here yeah i think
the wi-fi password with the pink it's
just got this let me give you a
suggestion it says what's the wi-fi
password that's the question that you
were gonna ask yo chris i've got a query
vasco sport water don't fear me when the
beat drops grateful flavor and a hop on
it the vitamins and minerals the
isotonic if you're hung over yeah i
might glow or do a frown at the guy and
it says ice power this is pretty great
you and i could click you do first aid
so solve it if the flow's so sick and
now from siem here's a little battery
pack got a little wi-fi qui charging
having that put it on my phone hold it
in your little chile oh photo hi mum i'm
glad to say a key ring coming from so
far you're like repping vw there on the
car in the bum bag that's a nice
position were you upset when they lied
about the emissions it got you in the
throat with the volkswagen golf some
lipstick put it there right above your
throat kiko milano let's discover i'm
gonna look in here it's a nice fuchsia
color i might think some people would
describe it as pink looking elegant like
you're wearing a mink it's me on the
phone for a 10 second clip this is so
damn old yeah you should slip it in a
new one what's this an iphone 6 or a
more nicer one whoa you think i'm a dick
looking at me saying there we go i'm
jealous of the turtleneck from this
fellow oh real nice thing comedy such a
charmer we could eat this and then peel
slip on a banana it's looking very long
we're having such fun only rapper on the
stage pulls in like a gun we begun any
other things from this chap there an
apple watch take it off your wrist don't
care let me see the weather i shout out
loudly tartu 14 degrees and cloudy and
let me talk about this i'm glad we asked
how the heck do you keep this on your
mustache it's going over there you'll
never let it relax you gotta get a
little tub and you're whipping out wax
like oh yes i'll say it again i'm
looking ever so posh like victorian like
an explorer there i'm glad we're having
fun i'm in tartu you should be in the
amazon there we go
[Music]
oh boy oh boy oh boy um
you guys have been real real nice